Getreu dem Leitmotto: 'Mission vorwärts'
schaut das Bundesheer in die Zukunft und achtet
dabei natürlich auch auf die Nachhaltigkeit.
Wir schauen uns gemeinsam an, wo im Bundesheer
das PEFC Siegel mit Projekten und Produkten
aus nachhaltiger Waldwirtschaft vorkommt.
Das Bundesheer verwaltet etwa 10.000 Hektar
Waldfläche. So wie hier am Truppenübungsplatz
in Allentsteig. Und bewirtschaftet diese nach
PEFC-Standards. Diese Form der Bewirtschaftung
ist uns ein besonderes Anliegen, weil
wir selbst Produkte aus nachhaltiger
Waldwirtschaft herstellen und nutzen. So
zum Beispiel hier im Heeresdruckzentrum,
unserer PEFC-zertifizierten Druckerei mit
rund 40 Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern.
Hier werden Broschüren, Folder, Plakate
und andere Druckprodukte hergestellt. So
wie unsere Sonderausgabe: 'Ein
Heer voller Möglichkeiten' das
hier produziert wurde und mit dem
PEFC Siegel ausgestattet ist.
Damit nutzen wir die wichtige Ressource Holz
aus garantiert nachhaltiger Waldwirtschaft.
Und Holz ist auch ein wichtiger Baustoff
in unseren Kasernen. So wie hier hinter
mir das Unterkunftsgebäude in der
Von-der-Groeben-Kaserne in Feldbach,
ist ein jüngst fertiggestellter Holzmodulbau.
Das nachhaltige und neuwertige Objekt bietet
210 Soldatinnen und Soldaten Unterkunft und
ist ein Muster für weitere Holzbauprojekte.
Auch in der Beschaffung achten wir auf
Produkte aus nachhaltiger Waldwirtschaft
wie z.B beim Papier. Wir verwenden wo
wir nur können Produkte mit PEFC Siegel.
Der Klimawandel, der geht uns alle an. Als
österreichisches Bundesheer leisten wir einen
aktiven Beitrag indem wir Papier und Holz aus
nachhaltiger Waldbewirtschaftung nutzen und das
zeigen wir auch mit dem PEFC Siegel auf all
unseren Druckwerken des Heeresdruckzentrums.